can you start with the
um image from reddit
of the notice that was posted on the
fence
okay so what you have now for those of
you who are listening
is a removal notice for the fence that
has been placed
in front of the courthouse this is the
city government
placing a notice on the fence that is
used to protect
the courthouse from nightly incursions
by
the protesters let me be clear the fence
was erected by
federal officers and the city of
portland this
the portland bureau of transportation is
declaring that the fence that was
erected by federal officers
is a hazard and must be removed it's a
hazard but but the fence was erected by
federal officers that's the piece i
didn't hear you
so the federal officers have been left
to defend these buildings because the
city is not enforcing the law
so the federal officers are defending
the buildings and instead of defending
them
against incursions that come right up
into
break into the building start fires all
of the stuff they put up a fence
to reduce the access of these nightly
rioters
the city is now saying oh you're
blocking traffic which is actually
nonsense
it is true that they do come into a lane
of traffic but it's not like the traffic
doesn't move it moves perfectly well
but the city is now effectively signing
up with the rioters to get the fence
removed the rioters try to remove the
fence every night and they frequently
succeed
um so the city has now uh taken a
position on these riots
um okay now do you want to go through
the slideshow
these are slides that you took uh these
are pictures that you took this morning
yeah
these are pictures i took this morning
so here things are calm
absolutely calm which is a reliable fact
they are calm every day
uh during daylight hours this is in the
park directly across
from the courthouse
this is a concession stand in which you
can get free ribs
they've named it riot ribs which is
funny
um but nonetheless this is an autonomous
zone okay it's undeclared but it clearly
is an autonomous zone
um these concession stands are there
every day okay can you advance one
here are city workers cleaning up the
nightly mayhem hey zach we can't tell
which
you're showing us two different pictures
we don't know what people can see at the
moment
okay can you go one more
okay here you see a huge number of
barbecues
okay this is absolutely an autonomous
zone these barbecues are there
they're being used to cook food um
keep going
okay that one is not in the correct
orientation but you can still read that
it says
get out of my city feds go home now
remember the rioters nightly attack
federal buildings
and the police the local police are not
enforcing the law
therefore i would argue that actually
the feds have no
choice but to defend those buildings i
mean legally speaking they have no
choice
and so in effect we are being set up to
imagine
that there is a federal incursion now
there are things about the way that
the um these this influx of federal
officers is going about their business
that make me uncomfortable
but it's also not as portrayed they are
taking people into unmarked cars but
they themselves are clearly labeled
as federal officers um
and so more pictures yep keep going
this one says there's no police force
like no
police force so when people tell you
that nobody is arguing for no police
force
in fact it's right here on this tree
keep going okay
our mayor our mayor is being taunted by
these people
right ted squealer and he's depicted as
a pig and of course pig means cop to
these people
um above it is a sticker that says gas
me teddy now i want to talk a little bit
about this term gas right the term
gas is being used to make everybody
squeamish
about tear gas now i don't like the idea
that tear gas is being used in portland
but the thing is tear gas
is an irritant right the term gas
evokes mustard gas it uh evokes
nazi gas chambers and zyklon b
so the point is the idea that ted
wheeler is
gassing people is being used
to make him squeamish about doing what
he absolutely must do
as the mayor and police commissioner
which is enforced a law which he is not
doing
um let's see the final sticker here says
talk to plants talk to plants not
cops now this is all very humorous
except
that um this don't talk to cops thing
is being used to make a an incident
a violent incident between the police
and the protesters
slash rioters more likely it's it's
divisive
it is dehumanizing uh we saw
the uh bits of this during occupy
of course it was considered treason to
talk to the cops
even though it is necessary to talk to
them frankly they are citizens too
and it is necessary that they understand
that they are not up against some
monolith but that they are up against
people i believe that you had a
conversation with a policeman
during occupy in olympia
in which you talked to him and i think
maybe even a couple of other of other
policemen
came around and were engaging
about the need to not follow orders when
orders are themselves immoral in moral
order
this is the conversation that you were
having with police and you were being
decried
by fellow protesters for engaging with
police yeah and that was a peaceful
protest that was a place
but you know that was actually you know
when we were being told to get off the
lawn so we didn't hurt the lawn
right like this that that was that was
what this is pretending to be
yep it is pretending and that is
uh from the point of view of the new
york times and all of your standard
democratic outlets the portrayal makes
one move
right the idea is this is all a reaction
to a federal incursion therefore
this is effectively trump deploying
troops to the streets of portland
because we always
were told that he was going to do this
this he was it was going to be a power
grab but the fact is
no no there were federal officers
defending these buildings because that's
legally required there are federal
buildings
and then this surge of new uh federal
cops is the result of the fact that
these city cops aren't doing their job
yeah i should point out the notice
saying that the fence was impeding
traffic and therefore had to go
is actually part of a deeper plan i am
told you are told by whom
well there were two people who had a
sign out
saying that they were offering free
legal advice to people who had been
released from jail
after having been arrested in the search
people on a portland
near in in downtown portland early on a
saturday
when there is no activity really but you
know patently sympathetic to the
protesters
and no evidence that they themselves are
you know adding to the chaos or the
anarchy
nope i would say these people uh
looked like they were probably folks who
knew what they were talking about
legally probably had been to law school
don't know but okay so what did they say
to you they said to me that
um the fence was impeding traffic where
it was
but to move it back towards the building
would violate the americans with
disabilities act
so
the americans with disabilities are
needing to go
inside the federal like like what i mean
what is the access that is
that's apparently the access but i mean
but but
okay yeah i mean i i don't i just don't
even know it's hard
it's hard to counter the argument
because i mean presumably you
and i would both want americans with
disabilities to be able to access this
building on the other hand
i don't want well they blocked a bike
lane earlier and i know we bike and we
don't want bike lanes blocked but
but for god's sake so here's the thing
if you're gonna argue that this uh
federal incursion is illegitimate
then it is your obligation to explain
what is supposed to be happening because
it looks to me
like they have gone up against every
tear and the last tier the only tier
that won't give
are the feds right i don't like that
that's not what's supposed to be going
on in downtown portland
but if the city is going to abdicate
responsibility and they're going to
attack a federal building which
obviously they are doing to precipitate
a federal response
you get rid of these smaller more local
more empathetic to your particular
phenomenon
hometown police and what you will get is
a police state
this is what will happen and that's not
what i think is that doesn't appear to
be the
goal by anyone here but this will be the
effect
of going after the smaller jurisdiction
policing which is
happening not just in seattle and
portland but in lots of places
so let's talk a little bit about the are
there more slides there zach
you want to go through the remainder of
them and then i'd like to talk about the
the next level here end the police
occupation of portland
i don't see that the police are occupied
portland i see
that rioters are occupying portland
i mean we've got effectively two months
of nightly
riots against federal buildings
so this is a false narrative that this
is the police occupying portland and it
implies of course if the police leave
everything will be hunky-dory
when effectively we can see that the
people who are demanding this
are attempting to light these buildings
on fire should we allow that
right okay keep going
trump nazis go to hell okay now this i
think
is the crux of it is that
we have a situation in which the
fact of trump in the white house and the
fact therefore that everything
federal looks to people on the left
like trump means that there is
um a total loss
of coherence right um
more slides so here you can see this is
clearly an undeclared autonomous zone
right these are this these are
concession stands set up
in a public park across the street from
this courthouse where nightly there are
riots
it's clearly an autonomous zone anymore
here is where uh rioters have
attempted to cut through the barricade
there are many of these breaches
and uh it is not difficult online to
find
video of the protesters shaking the
fence
down ripping it apart on a regular basis
anything else ah this is actually part
and parcel of what we were talking about
um before this model in which
the messages are being evolved
online okay here's a hashtag spray
painted
tear gas ted yeah okay
tear gas ted keep going
okay all cops are bastards no justice no
peace and that that bit of graffiti on
the far end says
[ __ ] you which in some sense i think may
be
the best description of what this means
here we see
on the justice center abolish usa
now you know be wonderful how many of
these people have ever been outside of
this country
i i mean this is this has been my my
point for months now
i mean years actually because we saw yes
we saw this at evergreen
that the the most susceptible to this
batshit ideology were the people with
the most naivete about what the world
actually looks like what different
people
sound like and and think like and eat
like
and what their music is and what it is
to be on the ground
in someone else's culture abolish the
usa
try going somewhere else and living with
other people for a while
in the conditions in which they live and
come back
to your home and let's talk then